um
coming up um
it's my great pleasure to introduce my
dear academic big brother child gal
um i use chicago statistics to talk
about mini max estimation for phase
synchronization
thank you so much
uh
can can you hear me
yes
oh great
okay it is my great pleasure to
tell you about some of the recent
progress that we have for this problem
facing causation
uh actually uh the title i submitted for
the workshop was uh iterative algorithm
for discrete structure recovery which
is a general framework that's supposed
to include synchronization as a special
case
but last night i was when i was
preparing the slides i realized i don't
have time to go through all the details
in the channel framework so maybe it's a
good idea to just focus on this problem
instead
and this is a joint work with my
wonderful collaborator
anderson john who is currently faculty
at wharton uh he is actually uh going to
give another talk on thursday in this
workshop
so let's start with the studying of
phase synchronization so we observe why
i yjk is understood as a noisy version
of the pairwise difference of two angles
and the goal is to estimate these angles
z1
through zn so each cj it is a complex
number the only constraint is the
complex numbers ej has normal one so for
a complex number has a unit norm
you can always parametrize that by an
angle
that's why
zj times the complex conjugate of zk is
understood as the difference of two
angles and the noise variable is just a
gaussian here the sternum gaussian is in
a complex phase uh it is defined as both
uh in measuring part and real part
sample id from normal zero one number
two and our goal is to estimate these uh
angles d1 through zn uh under uh the
normalized l2 laws so here you notice
the last definition we put a
minimization over a global rotation uh
the reason is because if you rotate all
the angles by the same amount then the
joint distribution of these data will
not be changed
so this minimization is to take care of
this
identifiability issue
so
the problem is quite famous in
the community of mathematic applied
mathematics and has been uh studied by
many people
and uh there are main three main
algorithms that have been discussed and
studied in the leadership the first one
is the mathematical estimator to
maximize the log likelihood function and
if you do some simple manipulation it is
equivalent to
this
quadratic programming algorithm a
programming uh problem
but since here we have the constraint
which is also quadratic so this is a
qcqp it is known to be conditionally
hard it looks simple but you cannot
actually compute it in condition in
polynomial time that's why people also
consider the following two
approximations and the first one is
called generalized power method the idea
is at each iteration you want to update
the value of each angle dj according to
this formula so if you look at the
numerator
it is just one of the entry of the
product between the data matrix y and
the vector z right that's why it's
called power method you converse
computer
product between y and z
and then for this vector what you do
next is to normalize
each entry of the vector
uh so that each entry has normal one
because you want to estimate angle
that's why you should project the vector
into okay that's why the algorithm is
called the generalized power method
and uh
and the the second approximation to mle
is a convex relaxation uh by a semi
different program so to
to derive this sdb it's actually very
simple you just need to rewrite the
object function of mle as the trace
inner product between two matrices the
data matrix y and then the matrix d
transpose so you want to uh
regard this as uh
an optimization over the matrix argument
the easy transpose and then what does
the matrix is transfer satisfied well it
satisfies two requirements the first one
is uh all the diagonal entries are one
and the second one is zd transpose is uh
psd right and this gives you the two
constraints that you have in sd it is
combat so it can be solved
efficiently
and uh these three algorithms have been
spelled well studied in literature for
example the 2017 paper by alfonso
bandera nicholas boomer and messinger
shows that the maximum likewise mata
satisfy the error bound with respect to
this loss sigma squared over n so this
is just the classical uh parametric rate
because uh here we have the problem with
sample size and squared
and the uh the dimension is m right so
this is just the classical dimension
over sample size rate and you can also
show this is the minimax rate of the
problem so sigma squared over n is the
minimax weight that can be achieved by
the max microwave estimate so what about
the other two estimator well in the same
paper uh by these three authors uh they
actually proved this a very nice result
that shows the tightness of the sdp
solution as long as an extra condition
sigma squared as at most of order whose
n is imposed under this condition then
uh the solution of sd is tight in the
sense that it is it must be rank one and
can be factorized into the outer product
of the
solution of the likelihood optimization
okay
and uh for the generalized power method
uh nicholas boomer himself uh back in
2016 uh proved as long as you initialize
the gpm algorithm from something
consistent such as the eigenvector delta
matrix then you can show the algorithm
converges to the mathematical estimator
as long as the condition sigma squared
is at most of order and q is imposed
right so
by the connection of gpm and sdp to mle
you can also claim
these two algorithms also achieve the
optimal
minimax rate sigma square over n
because of the convergence okay
and the two results have been improved
recently by
this paper ichao zhong and nikolas boomo
they used the level of argument in 2018
and was able to improve the condition
significantly to a sigma square as of
most of order and over log in okay so if
you remove the log and then this is the
sharp condition so this is uh
uh actually uh as i will discuss later
slightly uh
uh uh uh
stronger than what is necessary okay and
uh under the same condition by the same
author they
also was able to establish the sharpness
the tightness of stp
and showing sdp is rank one under
this this condition okay so this is what
we
know as the state of the art for the
phase synchronization problem in the
literature
if you look at the results there are
some
additional questions you can ask for
example now we know sigma squared over n
is mean max rate what about the leading
constant can we figure out a sharp
constant and if so
uh can we show some of the algorithms
that we have here are able to achieve
not only the minimax rate but also
because maybe some of them cannot
well
this is what we can
we want to present uh in our results
uh but i would actually like to present
the results in a slightly more general
setting by allowing the possibility of
missing data so i'm going to introduce a
random other training graph here uh the
adjacency matrix has uh
uh uh elements ajk uh that follows i the
bernoulli distribution with probability
parameter p so if aij is one that means
there is an edge connecting j and
k if this happens then you can observe y
j k
that's the uh a pairwise difference of
the and the j's angle and the case angle
otherwise if ajk is zero then you have a
missing b so we allow uh some missing
missing data by uh imposing this uh
by only assuming we have a partial uh
set of the pairwise relation between the
angles and it's the same problem that we
want to estimate the angles d1 through
zen under this last function
so this is the main result uh under
these two assumptions and i will come
back to the the assumption later first
of all we have a minimax lower bound
so if you look at the results when p
equals one indeed sigma squared over n
is the minimum x rate
uh but for general p uh the mean max
rate should be sigma squared over np and
uh and and also we characterize the mean
constant the outcome constant should be
at one over two and moreover we show
that all the three algorithms are
exactly optimal not just the rate but
also the leading console as well so the
mle
uh a gpm initialized by the eigenvector
of the data matrix
and the sdp solution uh with an extra
post process instead by extracting the
eigenvector
will all achieve
the minimized optimality
okay so now let's discuss these two
assumptions so the first assumption says
that the sequence space should be of
smaller order than mp
so uh when p equals one then you may
compare this one to the previous
condition that is in literature so the
best condition that we have in the
literature to establish the sharpness
are the tightness of sdb and gpm
is by a jungle and rule they require
sigma square to be a border n log n so
here when p is a constant then it's of
order a little o n
it's better but for general p
the condition becomes sigma squared is
little o of np so this is equivalent to
saying that the minimax risk goes to
zero right so in a sense
it is the necessary sufficient condition
for consistency
of course uh for those of you who are
more ambitious you may be wondering what
if sigma squared is uh of the same order
that as mp this is the regime where the
signal to rate noise ratio is a constant
uh uh it's actually also a very
interesting setting even though in this
setting the mini max risk is actually
constant but
it is still interesting to characterize
what exactly the constant is what we
know is when p equals one uh if you look
at the results in literature then uh uh
new uh various numerical experiments
will tell you that none of the three
methods are optimal okay uh when the in
the regime where the signal-to-noise
ratio
is a constant and when p equals one uh
uh when the signal phase ratio is a
constant uh uh then uh uh in literature
we know that the approximate passing
algorithm amp
is able to uh achieve uh uh the optimal
constant okay but uh when for general p
uh when the signal noise ratio is a
constant this is still an open problem
and the second condition that we need is
uh p is at least of order log n over n
this is just to make sure that the
running graph is connected it only has
one component
okay
uh we also have additional results for
sdp because the output of an sdp is a
matrix so if you are only interested in
matrix estimation if you want to
estimate the matrix dz transpose uh
under the normalized flowbenious norm
then we have a lower bound for that and
sdp without any post processing step
directly achieve
this
error as well all right so uh this is
the result and in the next part of the
talk i'm going to tell you how we can
actually establish these results
but instead of giving you directly the
mathematical proof let me just slightly
deviate from my topic and
tell you uh this paper this is a paper
uh that appeared in back in 2016
written by you and harrison jo
it's a winnable paper it analyzed the
signal property and the uh
performance of the
k-means algorithm that people use every
day in the context of gaussian mixture
model okay so if you have a gaussian
data from a generated from a gaussian
mixture model then you just run k-means
uh
in this paper by lou and joe they were
able to show that uh
in terms of the
clustering error
the error will go down exponentially to
the the minimax clustering error for
gaussian mixture model so which
characterize both aesthetical optimality
and the conditional efficiency of the
algorithm
the reason i want to mention the paper
here is i will try to convince you
actually mathematically
the gaussian mixture model and the phase
synchronization model they are quite
similar and actually uh they have the
same
mathematical essence
and the k-mean iteration
and the iteration that you see from the
generalized power method they can be
derived from the same mathematical
principle they're actually the same
problem okay so
this is by viewing both models as
special cases of this general structure
linear model framework so this is a
framework
which i proposed back uh back in 2015
together with otto vanderbot and
harrison joel
the goal back then was to understand uh
the behavior of a particular posterior
distribution for a general class of high
dimensional models and our goal is to
use this general framework to include
many
high dimensional models that people care
but it turns out
for today's purpose this framework is
also proved to be useful to understand
the performance of k-means and
generalize our message in base
synchronization
so
in this framework what you have is a
data object y
it can be written as the sum of a signal
part and a noise
right let's just ignore the noise part
the signal part has three components but
the first component is the structure
parameter z
that we're trying to estimate so here
uh z
stands for the clustering label in a
gaussian mixture model and in the
context of phase synchronization it is
just a
vector of an angle that you are trying
to estimate okay
and then we have the second component it
is the linear operator i use the
notation script x to denote that the
linear operator is indexed by the
structure of private so if you change
the value of z the linear operator will
be changed
and finally we have the parameter this
is the model parameter b
which is the last ingredient of the
structured media model so what the
linear operator does is to map
the parameters from it from the space to
the space where the data lives okay and
first of all i'm going to impose the
assumption that the parameter b
lifting some from the space and the
primary space is potentially of low
dimension it is also parameterized by
the same structure parameter you see
a
as an index of the linear operator as
well right so here i want to emphasize
that the structure parameter z appears
in two positions right the first as the
index of the linear operator and also as
the index
of the prime space
okay so with this general framework you
can actually uh rewrite many familiar
models as special cases uh for example
in clustering we have the gaussian
mixture model here the corresponding
linear operator just the maps the matrix
that consists of k
clustering centers
to
the expectation of the data matrix
and for the ranking task what we have
here is a very simple
pairwise difference model and what the
linear operator does is to map this
one-dimensional parameter beta to the
expectation of the data matrix
and then finally the uh
the linear regression model is also a
special case it's kind of obvious
because the linear operator is fully
determined by the design matrix of the
problem okay
so
so it turns out this is a very good
framework and it allows us to
write down a unified algorithm to
solve all kinds of different problems
with a single approach so here's a way
that we can construct such a unified
algorithm the first step is to write
down some local statistic tj okay so the
goal is uh to uh
that we hope is tj
can contain some information about the
jth component of the structure
parameters we try to estimate so the
only mathematical requirement we have
for tj is its expectation should be a
function of both the model parameter b
and the j component of the structural
parameter zj okay
so once this is true then you can just
write down the following naive
estimating procedure
so this is just a
search over all possible values a
such that the l2 difference of the
statistic tj
and the proposed expectation is
minimized right so that leads to a
procedure there's nothing special about
it
uh but actually uh you cannot use this
algorithm in practice because you do not
know the model primary right because
that's the only problem that we are
trying to address but the good news is
that we have assumed that the model
prime the b belongs to some parameter
space that is of low dimension and it is
also indexed by the same structure
parameter z that we're trying to
estimate
so in a sense if we know z
somehow we can use this knowledge as
maybe but we have no b
we can use this d squared formula to
estimate z right so this naturally uh
gives you a procedure that you can write
down this is exactly what we are going
to do by replacing b
uh with some estimator b hat of z
right so this b hat of z
is a global least square procedure but
assuming b belongs to the primary space
index by the structure partners
okay
and we also have a a a theorem to
guarantee the uh
statistical uh
error convergence for this uh
for this uh
general iterative procedure but first
let me introduce some notation
we are going to analyze the error of
this iterative procedure using this loss
function this is just the sum of the l2
difference between the mean function and
here the only difference between the two
mean functions
is in terms of difference of the
structure parameters here the first
place we have zj the second place we
have vj star okay
and we
and for those of you who are interested
gaussian mixture model if you want to do
clustering then
for clustering uh what you uh what is
natural to measure the error is the
having loss right
then there is a trivial lower bound you
can lower bound the l2 loss by having
loss multiplied by the signal difference
okay so as long as you can obtain a
bound for the algae loss this naive
inequality will also give you a bound
for the clustering error
all right so next i have two empirical
process type conditions uh
that i imposed using these actual
notations uh uh so here uh i apologize
for uh being sloppy uh if you want to
know the exact position of the
difference function uh these will be
made specifically in the paper
you can look at look at the definition
but it's quite complicated i don't want
to go to details but roughly speaking
what i require is that the ratio between
the difference between the two mean
functions
and the corresponding difference in
terms of loss
is a smaller order it's
little old one with high probability and
i also want this to be uniformly
uh holds
uh uh within uh uh
within the neighborhood the truth with
radius type okay it turns out this tower
characterized the dominant retraction of
the algorithm
and in the second condition it is i just
require the difference between the two
mean functions if one
if b star is replaced by an estimator
which assumes the knowledge of z-star is
also uploaded one with high probability
so under these two conditions
we can show
as long as you initialize the algorithm
within
the radius of tau here that's how it's
the same tile that appears in the
previous condition
and then
the algorithm in terms of the outer loss
will converge to what is called the
ideal error at an exponential rate right
so here ideal error again i i do not
make it make specific here but you can
specialize that
in many
uh specific problems it will usually
give you the minimum x rate of the
product okay
all right so let's
work out the specific example so the
first example we are going to do is to
specialize this idea to the gaussian
mixture model
okay so we have a gaussian mixture model
the i data point is a d-dimensional
gaussian vector
the expectation is given by theta sub z
i here z i is the clustering label of
the i to the point so what would be a
natural local local statistic well just
take the local status to be the is the
point
right and then compute its expectation
so the expectation function is theta sub
a
with this specification
you can work out
the general iterative procedure it turns
out to be exactly the k-means iteration
right
and if we specialize at the theorem to
the context of gaussian which model
what we can get is the convergence
guarantee for the k-means algorithm
under this setting
so in the assumption that the number
cluster k is a smaller order of the
sample size
and the signal to noise ratio condition
holds
you can show
that in terms of the clustering error in
the hamming distance
it goes down to the minimax rate of the
problem with
exponential convergence algorithmically
okay as long as you initialize the
algorithm uh uh
by some uh by something good such as
metrocluster
and now i want to emphasize this is
actually not my result this is precisely
the result uh by you and harrison joe
the point here is to
tell you you can actually
rediscover this result from a more
general
perspective okay so now we are ready to
actually analyze the phase
implementation problem use this more
general perspective of analyzing the
k-means right so here this is our phase
classification problem i just put
everything in matrix notation so we have
the data matrix y
written as zz transpose plus the noise
confidence gaussian random matrix
so
the first problem that you notice here
is
that uh
the mean structure is zz transpose right
it is it turns out to be a quadratic
function in terms of z
uh but our general framework is called
the strategy model so what we need is
linearity okay so uh this is some this
is uh an issue that we have
but turns out uh this is actually uh
where we can take advantage of the
flexibility of this uh structured linear
model
so uh uh uh uh uh previously i
emphasized uh a nice feature of this
framework is that
the structure parameter z can actually
appear in both places first as an index
of the linear operator and second as an
index of the parameter space and this
turns out can resolve this quadratic
dependence issue and we are going to do
that
so what we can do is to rewrite the
model
as z beta transpose
okay
and then this gives us the corresponding
linear operator which maps beta to z
beta transpose okay this is a
well-defined linear operator and what
about our prime space but the parameter
space for beta is just this trivial
space index by z it turns out to be the
space that only contains one element z
right
if you do that then you can this is how
you can recognize base synchronization
model as a special case
of the structured linear model framework
and now we have a representation that is
linear in z
instead of quadratic okay and then we
can derive the algorithm and the local
statistic is just the i column or you
can also use the ice role of the data y
i and
uh the mean function is a times beta
okay and we can
with with these two choices
and we can write down uh the general uh
iterative procedure as is okay so let's
try to solve these two optimization
problems the first optimization problem
is trivial because you if you look at
constraints you can
give you single set so
trivially
the answer to the first optimization
problem is just the z
value from the last step okay and then
you can plug the relation beta t equals
z t minus one to the second optimization
problem
and if you solve that what you can get
is exactly uh the iteration formula of
the generalized power mass okay so
indeed uh the generalized club iteration
that ken means algorithm are the same
they can be derived from the same
approach okay and if you want to allow
the possibility of missing data you can
simply replace y j k by the product of a
j k times y j k and this is just to be
more general okay so now i'm trying to
uh uh i will i will give you an analysis
of this iterative algorithm and and this
will give us a sharp upper bound for the
basic notation problem so i'm going to
define a notation f
f is a map that summarizes the evolution
of the
algorithm given by a a generalized power
method
okay and for this f
we have the following lemma which says
under the same two assumptions that we
have for the main theorem
uh for any gamma that is of all the
little one
there exists some delta also of order
little one such that uniformly over all
z
uh uh uh uh in the neighborhood of
z-star
uh the one-step iteration of z satisfy
this inequality right so here if you
regard z as the current step then f of z
is the next iteration result okay so in
terms of loss function it is found by
two terms the first term characterizes
the optimization error
which is the error from the last step
with an extra factor given by delta and
then the second term is exactly secret
squared over 2mp
this characterized the statistical error
for the phase synchronization model okay
so with this result uh an immediate
corollary is that the generalized power
method
after sufficient step of iteration will
achieve exactly uh the minimax
optimality
okay so that's the first result that we
can derive from this lemma the second
result is at the
theoretical guarantee for the
mathematical estimator
by recognizing that the solution of the
mle is actually the fixed point of this
map f right this means
uh if you
start
the generalized power method at the
solution of mle
it will stay unchanged okay and because
of this property the previous level that
characterized the property of the f also
gives you
uh the uh the statistical optimality of
this the fixed point of f which is the
max microestimate so here the proof
of the authority of mle is not through
analyzing mle directly but from
analyzing
uh this estimator from an algorithmic
perspective
okay
so uh
now
we are left with uh uh
the analysis of sdp okay so just end up
just like the analysis of the mle i'm
also going to analyze uh
the solution of sdp
from
an iterative perspective i'm going to
write down an iterative algorithm and
then relating the solution of sdp as the
fixed point of this iterative bandwidth
so this actually is given by a
non-convex perspective of the semi
different program so first let's try to
briefly review what we have for the mle
so this is the
optimization problem that we have for
the maximum likelihood estimator and as
we saw from the previous slide
uh
the generalized power method
characterize the mle because the mle can
be regarded as the fixed point of gps
okay
and for sdp
it has a similar relation
by observing that
the matrix z is always positive
semi-definite and for any positive
semi-definite matrix you can factorize z
as
the product of v transpose b
right
once you plug this factorization back
into sdp
uh you will get an equivalent
formulation of sdp
but this
formulation of sdp is optimization over
v not over
z right so it is a equivalent but it is
actually non-convex optimization right
so if you're optimizing over z it's done
it's convex but if you uh optimize overv
it's non-complex right it turns out
these two uh perspectives they are
equivalent
and this is actually a very well known
uh as the barometer factorization of
literature and people have been using uh
this vectorization to derive efficient
algorithms to solve sdp for a long time
and it is with this uh
non-convex representation
we can
write the solution of sdp as a fixed
point of this
uh
iterative algorithm right so
for this iterative procedure it is very
similar to the formula that you have in
the power method
you can
actually this as the generalized power
method
be
lifted
from one dimension to a higher n
dimensional space and this is what it
means okay
and next i'm going to
give a characterization of the evolution
of this alternative algorithm and use
that to solve the physical property of
the sdp okay so first we will use this
notation again f to denote the map
that gives the evolution of the
algorithm and then we have the same
lemma which also holds for the uh
for this evolution of the algorithm that
corresponds to sdp right so here the
only difference is uh in order to
measure
uh the closeness between a matrix b and
the vector z star we actually need to
slightly generalize the loss function
but here is the definition it's actually
not very hard to write on the definition
otherwise it's exactly the same result
as what we have already seen for
generalized power message
okay and with this lemma uh we uh we
immediately write down uh the statical
optimality of sdp
uh by realizing uh that the solution of
sdp can be written can be factorized as
v hat transpose v hat where we had
satisfied the fixed point problem
since
sdp achieves statistical optimality
in these loss functions
and here
for the third loss function
a z hat is actually
a
the normalized leading eigenvector of
the matrix d hat because the output of
the sdp is always a matrix that you want
a vector estimator a post processing
step is unnecessary unless you can show
an sdd is random but sometimes it's not
okay uh this is uh the upper bound i
want to uh uh uh uh all the upper bound
results that i want to discuss
so next let me briefly discuss the lower
bound proof uh the lower bound proof is
actually quite standard and there is
really
a
not much
to talk about
it's it's just a standard argument so
the first step is to write down the
definition of the minimax risk
uh here the only issue that we have for
the loss function is because the actual
minimization of a global rotation which
results in the now
non-separability of the loss function
right so without this minimization we
have a separate loss then you can
distribute the problem to each
coordinate but now we cannot
but there is there is an easy trick to
resolve this issue is to use this
inequality to lower bound the original
loss by the frobenius loss okay which
turns the problem of estimating
each angle to the problem of estimating
all the pairwise difference of different
angles right and the forbiddenious loss
is clearly
separable and then you can use the
single argument which lower bounds the
minimax risk by the business and because
of the probability of the forbidden loss
you can then distribute the id prior to
each pair z z k sorry j k okay and for
each pair
uh we can apply the well-known uh event
trees inequality to work out the optimal
uh a base risk every add everything up
uh this is the result of the lower bound
okay and that's how you
can improve lower bound for uh uh
not for just for phasing violation but
for general uh simplification problems
okay so uh if i have some additional
time let me also quickly go through the
problem c2 synchronization which is uh
very related to phase synchronization
it's actually a simple setting and you
also have the observations djk equals
zjz
yjk equals zjzzk plus gaussian noise but
here the premise space is even simpler
each cj can only take two values either
negative one or one so you can regard
this problem as a discrete times the
version of the phase synchronization
problem right each angle is only allowed
to take two values
and we also allow the possibility of
missing data and the goal is to estimate
these and discrete numbers
and again in the literature
have three algorithms the mle
generalized power method stp the
formulas are almost identical
and here is our result under the same
assumptions we have first will have a
lower bound and then we also have an
upper bound
for all the three methods
uh the only difference that you see from
this result uh compared with the result
of base synchronization is here the
minimax risk is actually an exponential
function of the signal-to-noise ratio
right
the reason is here
we want to estimate a discrete parameter
so in terms of the mathematical essence
this is more like a
other testing problem right so
uh
it is known that the optimal hypothesis
testing error is exponential in terms of
polynomial
which gives the exponential rate that we
have here whereas for fixed
synchronization you estimate the
continuous parameter and that's why
you have a polynomial permission rate
so i want to advocate this paper
by uh in jfe and we don't chen
back in 2020
they actually
they were able to prove uh the
optimality of sdp uh uh when p equals
what they obtained the exactly this
result so our result can be regarded as
a generalization of this
for a general p
the reason i think uh their paper is so
important is because
uh
the semi-deficit programming is
is known as a continuous optimization
problem
right so for z2c for these three
problems such as d2 synchronization it
is not obvious it will capture the
discreteness
of the problem so for a long time
what people can only establish for the
performance of sdp is a polynomial rate
the paper by three and chen is the first
time in the literature that
that rigorously proved
uh the performance of stp for this
degree type discrete problem is actually
exponential right that's a big
achievement
and if i remember correctly uh the error
exponent in infinity is also sharp they
get a sharp exponent okay
uh so here
our result is more general we have a a
general p but actually uh uh uh
the major difference is the difference
of proof the proof of ours is uh
completely different from uh the
approved by freya and chen they directly
analyze
a and p from the definition of the
objective function but we analyzed the
performance of sdb from the bare
material factorization point
and i think
this is a very good point of view
because it allows us to compare the
difference between phase synchronization
and z2 synchronization because
the way we prove uh the optimality of
these results are actually derived from
the same method right both are based on
parameter
factorization
and here i list the different optimal
error for the two sdp
and also the definition of the two sdp
well you may be curious to notice that
the definition is exactly the same so
what's going on actually they are not
exactly the same right they're literally
trying to hide something very important
right so the main difference between the
two stp is for syn phase synchronization
uh the optimization is over all complex
made these but for a v2 synchronization
the optimization is over or real
matrices and this is the only difference
right so if you optimize
uh this objective over all real matrices
then it turns out to capture the
discrete structure which will give you
exponential rate okay
and the reason that we the fact that we
have a single proof for the two
different results allows us to carefully
study the proof argument and to single
out the following main mathematical
ingredient that highlights the
difference between the two results it
turns out the main difference lies in
this interesting
but simple to prove inequality
so here
the results as the follows
we have two vectors two complex vector
x and y
let's assume y is a unit vector
then
if you want to bound the difference
between the normalized version of x and
y
you will get what appears on the right
hand side
okay
now on the right hand side you look at
the numerator you notice this term which
only depends on the imaginary part of y
transpose x
right and this turns out to be the term
that only
that is only present if you have complex
x and y
if you replace the setting by real x and
y then this term disappears
and when you analyze
uh the evolution of the iteration
for a sdp or phase synchronization
problem it is exactly this imaginary
term that gives you the polynomial rate
the exponential rate is always there
right for z to synchronization this term
does not
it's not present and therefore you only
have the exponential rate of convergence
and that's the difference okay
all right so uh that's almost the end of
the talk and uh i would like to use the
last slide to tell you a generalization
from phase synchronization to a general
rotation synchronization so here the
model is a noisy observation of the
paralyzed difference between two
rotation
z i z j are members from the rotation
group so
it's just the two-dimensional patient
which exactly is the phase
implementation problem well i don't
think this is a trivial extension
because uh we know that for sod
the group is not commutative uh uh
as soon as d is at least three okay uh
so this is actually the main difficulty
for the organization but anyway uh we
are able to obtain uh the result by uh
deriving
a new uh perturbation
inequality which is sharp
uh for quality condition under this
context
and the results uh shows that
uh the minimax rate is a state of order
a sigma over mp but the leading constant
is given
by d minus one times the amount uh
divided by two which turns out to be
the correct degrees of freedom of the
sod group
okay so this is all that i want to share
and thank you for the attention i think
i can take some questions
thank you child for the very interesting
talk um
we do have time for a few
questions chad this is so thanks for the
uh super interesting talk um i just
wanted to okay i have one quick question
which is um
you mentioned this argument for uh the
rank one case and then the ranking case
for the sdp
um
is it true that your argument would work
for the rank k puero montero
factorization as well or is there
something special about one and then i
just want to double check
uh hi joe uh first of all could you tell
me what run ksdp sdp
is
like in what context uh if i were to do
the buero montero kind of
um factorization where v is n by k
instead of n by n oh i see your point
yeah does your argument directly work in
that case yes so here uh our k is n and
when k equals 1 is the just the power
method so your question is uh whether it
works for just k for example k equals
root or something right
yes
okay uh uh i
do not have a specific answer uh i can
only uh uh give you a very naive answer
so
i believe the result will work
or a k that is a sufficient large
for example uh it is possible that as
long as k is root n
then it may work uh because uh uh if i
remember correctly root n is the
turns out to be the threshold that uh
the algorithm
gave you the local sorry the global
optima
but we did not prove it
thanks
i do have maybe one one other question
which is so you mentioned in your lower
bound
um
for the complex case you use this
ventries argument
um in this standard reduction i was
wondering is the exponential lower bound
for z2 the same or is it something
different
so the for the expenditure rate uh
everything before the ventris inequality
is the same and then for that particular
step
it's just the a lemon pearson and then
you can analyze the testing error
directly
even simpler
um hey just a couple of questions thanks
for the nice talk um the first one just
is uh is off the the little identity you
you said in the end about the complex
case versus the real case so if right
is it correct is the following
interpretation correct if z star
is actually real so it's plus minus one
but then you use the sdp in the in
complex space then it's automatically
adaptive that it actually gets an
exponential rate
because that second term you know depend
on okay
right a very good question uh if you
know uh so if the truth these star uh uh
uh uh you know uh is either plus or
minus one but use uh but you use sdp in
a complex space
uh it will still give you the polynomial
rate uh because here uh the inequality i
didn't say it only depends on the truth
it actually depends uh on some other
quantities
i see okay that makes sense um the
second question sorry just one one other
quick question
um
so you you presented this
sort of in this general
discrete iterative method thing that you
were talking about
so when you were talking about
clustering i was thinking to myself okay
this is lloyd
but
lloyd is actually not consistent in the
means right because if you initialize
lloyd
at the true means it doesn't get get you
the means
and then you sort of specialized in the
synchronization case by saying okay it
doesn't really matter there's no you
don't really care about the means
but then in the general discrete case is
there like a version of em or something
that still applies in your structural
linear model
uh yes a very good question uh if you
want to estimate the parameter uh which
in my uh structure
uh uh in a model uh notation it's b
uh then uh uh you know uh for example in
gaussian mixed model you use lloyd's
iteration it's inconsistent this is
actually known as the nameless phenomena
so in general
the the algorithm for the general
setting does not work for
uh for for b right so uh
uh it will be a very interesting
direction to actually analyze a general
em algorithm as you suggested
or maybe a variational base
and these algorithms will be able to
recover
a you know a continuous parameter be
in optimal way but we haven't done that
thanks
thank you
are there any more questions
let's thank chow again
[Music]
thank you